okay
hello everyone welcome to another
episode of science and technology q a
for kids
and others i see we have a number of
questions that got
left over uh from a previous time
and um there's a question from turkey
here
asking so so one of the things that's uh
uh
is asking about recording different
kinds of things about one's
life um you know one of the things that
i
have done for many years
more than 30 years now is sort of record
data about myself and what i'm doing
and honestly if it took me a lot of
effort to do it i wouldn't do it
but i've set up systems that you know
record every keystroke i type
they take screenshots of my computer
you know i've recorded all the emails
all text messages all these all these
different kinds of things
recorded lots and lots of things um and
uh uh occasionally i'll go and look at
these things
um and for some things like emails it's
you know really worthwhile to be able to
search them and that's kind of how i
um how i augment my memory
of things um for other things it's more
like
let's analyze this let's find out i mean
for for instance i
i found out things about myself because
i measured my you know continuous heart
rate for quite a few years things like
that and i can measure
oh you know when uh
i i discovered for example that when i
walk outside
instead of uh walking like on a
treadmill or something to get
my exercise every day that makes my
heart rate go down so i don't know why
but but
um it's just an observation um and uh
uh then um things like when i when i
finish a big project
um when i'm in in this late months of
finishing a big project
i usually end up uh maybe my metabolism
goes up and i weigh less than things
like this so they're all kinds of weird
things i discover about myself
um the uh
um so uh the question was
what what i record and um
uh things like what i know about things
i've
i've i've said and so on you know i i
have recorded as i say i've got about
three million emails that i've recorded
over the last 30 years
um and uh i've been meaning to do some
analyses like when did i first mention
this or that word when did i first
mention the word blog
because you know languages evolve so
there are words that
like the word blog came into existence
in english at some point
um and it just didn't exist before then
and there are other
words that i probably started using at
some time i think i did this analysis
for names of functions in our wolfram
language which got invented at some
point
they just didn't exist as words before
that they got invented and then i start
mentioning them
and so it's sort of a question for me
personally looking at the evolution of
language i mean we know
when we look at something like english
the english as used by shakespeare is
different from the english that we use a
few hundred years later
um and there's sort of the question of
how what is the
what is the evolution of language what
does it look like and for me personally
over the course of 30 years what does
the evolution of my language look like
so to speak
um and so a question
of what um um uh
you know there are some principles about
how language evolves like one of the
principles i always
i always find fun is uh you know when i
write things and so on and um uh people
proofread them
and they'll say that word is spelled
wrong about some word
well the one thing that is is uh let's
say it's a two-word thing let's say it's
a
a word like website web
space site right one of the things that
happens
in english at least i'm probably sure it
happens in other languages as well
is over the course of time words that
are used together a lot
get smooshed so for example
website is now usually spelled as one
word website no space between
it another word that i thought was was
not smooshed actually is long standing
i noticed in something that i wrote
recently somebody corrected that
that um you know long standing i thought
was long dash
standing but probably the very fact that
i said that probably dates me
of oh that that person learned to spell
in the 1960s or something
because in modern english that's
smooshed as one word
so it's an example of kind of evolution
of language and that's something that's
always happening and
and there are new words that could
introduce sometimes there'll be a word
that like blog for example
that really that came from weblog and
got shortened to blog
um those kinds of things um occasionally
there'll be
there'll be names of products that sort
of eventually just become part of the
language much to the horror
of uh typically of the companies that
invented those names because one of the
rules in
in law about uh trademarks if you say
i'm using a um i'm making
a famous example and making a xerox copy
might just mean i'm making a photocopy
of something
um but xerox is a company
still um that uh uh you know was
involved in making
uh photocopy well xerography it was
actually
greek words xcr
i guess sakai epsilon omega
sigma um it's a it's a greek word which
means dry
because that was the that was the big
innovation of making photocopies
where where you just made the photocopy
as a dry sheet of paper before that
when i was young um when you made copies
of things it involved some complicated
sort of
semi-photographic process that involved
liquids and so on so there were
sort of non-dry photocopiers but the big
innovation of xerox was the
the the zerography the dry copying type
idea but in any case the you know the
word
that means making a copy um
it's like um uh there's the generic
making a copy and then there's this
specific brand name
xerox that is um uh
um is supposed to be something that a
particular
company owns and the way law works at
least in the us
is there's this idea of trademarks which
is if you
use a word to describe
a thing that is related to a product or
service that
you have then it um uh
if you can but by the very fact that
you're doing it and you're selling
things under that name
um the uh within that class of of goods
that you're selling
let's say photocopies or something or
copying devices
um there is an assumption that you're
the one who can
if you've developed a lot of effort
selling things
under that name that you're the one who
gets to control that name
um at least so long as the name isn't
so generic that um uh
uh that that you can't use it as a as a
trademark and so you know names like i
don't know
apple and so on people argue about
whether that can be um
how that you know what that can be a
trademark for and that that has long
been settled in that particular case
but but um in any case so so that's
another way that
you know another way that words can can
enter
but but so so the answer is i haven't
really looked at the evolution of my
personal vocabulary but
i wouldn't mind doing so i think the
question was about audio recording
that's a more troublesome thing because
i've tended not to do that because
although i've been doing it increasingly
as we as we do meetings that are
uh through you know things like zoom and
so on
where uh which we've been doing for
years actually um
where there's more of an expectation
that you're going to record the thing
um generally uh in sort of everyday life
um it doesn't feel like the right thing
to be recording
everything one says to i i don't mind
recording the things i say
but uh to record everything everybody
else says is kind of
kind of odd um and i don't think that's
sort of a it's not a socially doable
thing you know i used to have a little
camera
that i used to clip on that um
uh used it was was that took a picture
every 15 seconds or so
and um i found uh in most kind of
social settings that was a uh i tried to
figure out you know could i
draw a little picture of an eye on it to
show what it was or some such other
thing
because people were very confused by it
um and uh you know
did it really make any sense in the end
i decided that for sort of
most social settings it was just so
weird it was just uh
you know in your face quite literally
weirdness
that was unnecessary but the one case
where it was very useful is that
at things like trade shows and i suppose
if i went shopping although i don't
usually
um it would also be useful there it's
you're going to a trade show and there
are all these booths where different
companies
are are selling different kinds of
things and you wander around there for
for a few hours or a day or something
like that and it's um i
i am uh i i use this little camera for
that
because it's a really useful thing
because instead of having to remember
oh i walked up to this booth and that
was interesting and i had this
interesting conversation for 10 minutes
with somebody
it's like all that data is right there
and you can
use you can just take those images and
you can recognize
the you know you can you can do optical
character recognition to recognize the
words
and you can you can turn that all into
something you can use so that's a
that was that was a one use case there's
a question here
uh about does the system record all
passwords that i use well
it does key logging so yes it records
everything i type
um and that's some
um okay
let's see there was a question here
which seems very
uh pertinent for mikhail how do vaccines
work
all right let's see if i can i can
tackle that one
um all right so
first question is um
let's see where to start here so
um the
basic thing that happens when you get
infected with something
is you've got some foreign thing in your
body
some antigen in your body that's a
foreign thing that you don't want there
and what you really want is for your
immune system
to go and attack that foreign thing and
get rid of it
well how does it know it's a foreign
thing how does it attack it how does
that work
in the end so in the case of viruses
it's kind of an uh a difficult thing
because a virus
takes over the the operation of one of
your cells a bacterium
is a cell itself and just circulates
around your body
and um you can kind of you can things
like antibiotics for example can affect
the virus
um quite quite separately because
they're separate cells in your body
um and uh for example you can have
something which could recognize
oh that's a that's a bacterial cell as
opposed to that's
a cell that's part of of of you yourself
so to speak
and the case of virus is a little bit
more complicated because the virus
actually goes in
and sort of takes over the um the the
system inside your cells that makes
proteins in your cells and so on
and makes makes copies the virus instead
of making
things that your your cell kind of
should be making so to speak
so so to recognize a cell that has been
infected by a virus but when you get a
virus
what happens is some small fraction of
your cells get infected
by the virus and the virus will take
over those cells
how do you recognize those cells well
the point is that
that cells all our cells
have a mechanism where they take the
proteins that are being made inside the
cells
and they take little pieces of those
proteins and they have a sort of
conveyor belt
mechanism with molecules basically that
takes those those fragments of
of proteins that are getting made of um
uh actually of the the the rna that's
the template for those proteins
and moves them to the cell surface and
exposes them on the cell surface
and so it's kind of like it's it's kind
of a a declaration
of um uh what's inside the cell
i mean all our cells are kind of
declaring on their cell surface
something about what's going on inside
the cell and that's what potentially
allows one to recognize oh whoops that's
a a cell that's been taken over by virus
we'd better do something about it now in
the end
the thing that does something about it
is one of our white blood cells
a particular kind called the killer t
cell is the thing that eventually
will go and uh and basically
kill off that infected cell um
so that it can no longer uh so the virus
inside it can no longer replicate and so
on
okay so how does that how does any of
that stuff work
basically what has to happen is you have
to
in your body the immune system which is
basically well there's two pieces to the
immune system there's a so-called
primitive immune system
that exists in uh even lower organisms
and there's the um uh the so that's the
so-called innate immune system
then there's the adaptive immune system
which is the thing that us mammals and i
think a few levels down from mammals
have
um that is an immune system
where where it is continually adapting
and learning
from things that it's seen before and so
uh the immune system that's relevant for
vaccines and so on is the adaptive
immune system
the higher level immune system that that
us mammals have for example
okay so how does this work well
the um the basic idea is that
you're you're trying to recognize what
cells are declaring things that are just
uh proteins
rna fragments whatever that are things
that are
that you are part of you versus what are
declaring things that are
some foreign invaders how do you tell
that
well the um what you what basically has
to happen
is that there are um
uh you're it's it's a very kind of
mathematical thing
in the end you're exposing sequences of
genome sequences you know a t
g c t et cetera et cetera et cetera and
you're asking
does this particular genome sequence um
occur in in me
or does it never occur in me and by the
time
if you just asked so so our genome
sequences
consist of about for humans about us
humans that that's
who we're all that's that's who's having
this discussion here
um is uh consists of about six billion
base pairs each base pairs of just a
particular configuration of atoms
um that are all strung together on our
dna molecules
and um each each of those base pairs a
handful of atoms maybe a
dozen or two atoms representing each
base pair
and and that um is uh
uh and those are there are four
possibilities
on the dnas has two strands but that
doesn't that's not relevant for what
we're talking about here
but there's that each of us is kind of
specified by the particular sequence
of six billion atgc
uh um base pair sequences there are
these four possible bases
um atcg and um
we're specified by the the the sequence
of six billion of those things each of
us has a different six billion uh of
those things slightly
uh the the there's there's rather small
differences i think um
what fraction is it it's um
i've forgotten i think it's about about
700 000 are usually
absolutely unique to an individual
person um and many more than that
differ between people but there will be
many uh sort of people who have that
same uh
sort of different piece of the sequence
so okay
that's that's how you sort of specify us
as the six billion base pairs
like the attacking virus the the
the virus the coronavirus that's caused
us all this pandemic trouble
it has only 29 000 base pairs so it's
really tiny compared to our
uh our six billion base pairs um
but uh the question is
what um if if a piece of that
viral genome
was the thing that was exposed on the
surface of the cell representing the
fact that sort of declaring the fact
that
there's some of this stuff going on
inside the cell
how would we tell that a piece of that
if there's a piece of that virus genome
exposed
as compared to a piece of our normal
genome exposed
and i i i think the the there's the
question is how many
atgc et cetera et cetera do you need to
have
before it becomes extremely unlikely
that
um that that that sequence will occur
um uh well okay so so within us
if we look at let's say length
let's say length 10 sequences there are
length 10 sequence of a t g c et cetera
et cetera
there are four to the power 10 um
possible
uh uh possible length ten sequences
because
at every position there's four
possibilities and there's ten such
positions
so it's four times four times four times
four ten times gives the total number of
possible
sequences of length 10. so 4 to the 10
is let's see roughly uh roughly a
trillion i think
um so that means that of a length 10
sequence there are trillion possible
sequences of length 10.
so the chances are in our 6 billion base
pairs
the chances are there'll be plenty of
those length 10 sequences that just
don't occur
in our 6 billion base pair length
piece of dna and let's maybe make it a
bit longer let's say
length 12 that would be let's say um um
that that would be let's say 200 you
know a few hundred trillion
um uh different possible length 12
sequences
okay so if you if you say okay then then
um
uh but it could be the case but
[Music]
that if we compare that now with what
exists in let's say the virus the virus
will have
different length 12 sequences and the
chances are
that it's the length 12 sequences in its
viral genome will be length 12 sequences
that just never occur in our genome
okay so as soon as you see that length
12 sequence
declared on a cell surface it's saying
oops that's not something that came from
us that's some foreign thing
maybe that's something like this virus
okay so so the basic thing you're
looking for is
sequences that basically we know
can't be part of us and therefore have
to be some some sort of foreign attacker
okay so that's that's the basic thing
you're looking for
the the question is what's the actual
mechanism for recognizing these foreign
sequences
okay so again biology is always quite
complicated and i'm not sure
it's always even difficult for me to
remember all the different pieces of of
how all this works
but let me try and give you a rough
overview
okay so there are these things called
antibodies
famous uh famous idea antibodies are
associated with b
cells which are a type of white blood
cell um
the um the the idea of antibodies
they are a type of molecule
immunoglobulin they're a type of protein
um and they have that they're usually
they're kind of y-shaped molecules
and one feature they have is that there
are many different variants
of these of this antibody molecule of
this immunoglobulin these aminoglobulins
and those many different variants
basically
correspond to they have representations
of different possible
genome-like sequences on them and they
they have these variable regions so so
your average protein in your body
there's just one form of it
you know your average i don't know
muscle protein actin let's say
or your average whatever there's you may
have a variant that's a little bit
different than somebody else's
version of that protein but they'll
typically be just one
different one configuration one one form
of that protein with one particular
uh sequence that of of amino acids that
makes it and so on
in the case of these uh antibody
immunoglobulins
um there are many different possible
sequences so there's this region
on the antibody that has a high
variation it's a sequence that has
of which there are many possibilities of
what it can be i think in in the case of
standard antibodies there are maybe 10
billion
different possible antibodies that can
circulate in us
so what is the point of these antibodies
the point of these antibodies is they
uh of these 10 billion antibodies they
are basically looking
for particular sequences that might be
exposed on the surface of a cell
and the way biology is you know sort of
works all through biology
is biology is about kind of molecules
that fit into each other
so for instance you know one molecule
may have a particular hole that's a
particular shape
and another molecule maybe just have a
little
sort of proboscis that sticks out that
fits in that hole
and so then those two molecules will
bind to each other and the result will
be some chemical
process that will be sort of a have a
chemical consequence
that is part of the operation of a
biological system
so the same thing is what's happening
with these antibodies
they have uh the 10 let's say 10 billion
different kinds of antibodies with each
with little different
sort of sequence regions on them and
depending on which cells depending on
what the
exposed sort of declaration on the
outside of cells is these antibodies
will either
a particular one of those 10 billion
antibodies will either bind or not bind
to that cell and so essentially what's
happening is and i i'm
i'm forgetting the actual lengths of the
um
uh sequences there on the order of 10
but i i forget how how long the actual
uh sequences are that um that are that
are used for these identifications
um the the thing the idea is
that uh all your various antibodies ten
billion different kinds of antibodies
that are sort of randomly generated in
your body um the randomly generated by
the
uh um uh different b cells
will each generate a different kind of
antibody and they'll be randomly
generated
um and you'll get sort of a random
collection of these 10 billion
antibodies
and then some of those antibodies will
be the antibody that binds to
the particular sequence associated with
those with the virus
let's say or with fragments of the virus
and will be the things that are exposed
on the surface of cells that have been
infected by the virus
so then what happens is that those so
that's the normal state of affairs these
antibodies are going around that kind of
searching around they're trying to find
you know is there anything is oh i i
forgot one very important thing
when you're a kid these antibodies are
trained
to the the whole system is trained to
recognize
what sequences are just part of you
and what sequences should be thought of
as being foreign intruders
so when when you're a kid you
that's particularly associated with
think of the thymus gland which is some
gland in the sort of
chest type area um and uh
that is is active when you're when
you're a kid and
it's part of of sort of training your
immune system to know what's you
and what's uh and what's what should be
considered a a foreign outside intruder
so to speak
and so that's so what what happens is um
most of the time you know that the whole
system of antibodies and so on they go
around and
and most of the time it's it's like if
if something is just
i'm i'm forgetting a little piece of
this this whole setup but but basically
what's happening is when it's something
that is known to be just you
the thing says oh that's fine that's
that's something that's just you not a
problem
occasionally if you're infected by a
virus or if they're bacteria
that invade you or whatever else the
thing will say no no
that's the thing that's something that
isn't just you
that's something different and it will
then bind to that and that will start a
cascade
that makes more antibodies of that kind
be produced more b
cells get produced more antibodies of
that type get produced
and that's how we mount a defense
against an
uh an attacking infection so
what's happening is the this random set
of you know all these different
antibodies
10 billion different kinds of antibodies
or whatever all circulating around
if one of them um is a match for some
intruder
that it will that will be detected and
more of that kind of antibody will be
produced
what's the point of the antibodies the
point of the antibodies is they
essentially mark
cells that are like this is a bad cell
once the antibody is bound to it's kind
of known to be a bad cell
and then other kinds of cells these t
cells um
come and know that this marked cell
should be killed off and so they then go
and do that
um uh do that work of killing off the
cell but the antibodies are kind of
marking
which cells should be should be killed
off and
um so okay so then then in normally what
happens is
you get an infection all those 10
billion antibodies are all
going around and eventually uh you know
the the infection will be recognized by
whatever antibody
is a match for the fragments of the the
genome whatever of the infector
um and then those uh
um those those antibodies
will be will be amplified and you'll
gradually mount this immune response
over the course of you know a few days
or something
you'll mount this immune response and
more and more antibodies will be
produced more and more cells will get
marked
more and more t cells will come in and
kill those cells and you'll fight off
the infection
that's kind of the normal way that the
adaptive immune system fights off
infection
okay what's the point of a vaccine the
point of a vaccine
oh i should explain another thing once
you've been affected with something
then there will be forever
some sort of memory b cells some some
memory
of the fact that this is something this
is a kind of antibody
that's worth having around because gosh
that's a kind of infection that exists
in the world
of all the 10 billion possible
antibodies most of them have probably
never been associated with any actual
infection
that's ever existed anywhere but the
ones that have been
are the ones that in your lifetime you
have been exposed to
you will end up with a mechanism for
keeping around more of the b
cells that make those antibodies and so
what will then happen is
if you ever get that attacked by that
you know by that
uh infector infective agent again
then your immune system will be much
more ready to jump into action
produce antibodies start this whole
mechanism
get rid of the um uh the the attacker
much more efficiently than it was first
time around because first time around it
had to kind of notice
oh yeah one of these circulating
antibodies is a match for this attacker
let's amplify that etc etc etc second
time around
you've probably got some whole bunch of
of
b cells and their corresponding
antibodies ready to jump into action
and immediately start attacking the
thing that's that's um that's infecting
you
and chances are they'll attack that
attack will be mounted before you even
know that you have the infection
um before you even start up all these
other cascades that
increase your fever you know give you a
fever and all these other kinds of
things a whole different
different story about how that works but
so the question is um okay so given that
whole set up
what's the point of a vaccine the point
of a vaccine is to give you
the equivalent of having had uh exposure
to uh to that antigen to that infecting
agent to give you the equivalent and to
have you have mounted
a similar kind of antibody response
and to give you that that same sort of
collection of b
cells and so on that will be capable of
remount of in of mounting a response
were you to actually be infected by that
agent so
when you uh if you get a vaccine for
something i don't know
measles or something like this then the
idea is
that you will mount
an immune response at the time of the
measles vaccine
and that immune response will be
sufficient to
get your immune system kind of teach
your immune system
how to make antibodies um that
can deal with a genuine measles
infection if one came along later
so that's the idea so first there are
many many different issues
so one one issue is that
um there's the question of
okay how come your immune system
uh when you get the measles vaccine is
responding strongly enough
to give you the same kind of immunity
that actually getting measles would have
because you don't want to if the measles
vaccine
gave you measles then kind of that's
pointless
what you want is the vaccine to get your
immune system
so energized that it will mount a big
immune response to measles
without you actually getting measles and
having
having the disease being sick so how
does that work
so it's a trick which was discovered
what by genuine people
150 years ago is that right roughly
um the um and the
the trick is that okay so first point is
you might um uh
let's say you just give somebody a very
tiny amount
of the um measles as a virus a little
tiny amount
of that virus um let's say you gave that
virus in a form
again i have to explain a few other
things here but um
let me let me make the main point is you
you're
what you've got to do is put something
in your body
which sort of walks and talks like
a measles virus or whatever
um but can't actually
infect you in the way that that virus
can can infect you
actually um and and so what happens is
the there are different schemes for how
different kinds of vaccines work there
are live virus vaccines
killed virus vaccines virus fragment
vaccines
etc um the but the idea
is that you you are going to get
injected into you
something which is something like the
virus that
could infect you and the idea is that
the thing that gets injected into you as
the vaccine
is going to be something which to your
immune system
looks like the thing that the virus that
might subsequently attack you um and so
your immune system will then say
okay this is an antigen i want to mount
an attack against this antigen um and
and
and then so it will end up mounting this
immune response which will give you
uh which will then produce this whole
sort of collection of memory b cells et
cetera et cetera et cetera
that will remember the um uh the the
that particular kind of antigen and give
you defense against that antigen
okay the problem is how do you get the
immune system
to be uh sort of energetic enough
in saying i want to mount a really big
immune response
so that i store lots of make lots of
memory b cells and so on
and store lots of stuff away without you
getting sick
without you having to get sort of a
systemic infection so to speak
um to to get the immune system to be
that active
so the trick is uh an additional kind of
substance that's part of
a vaccines i guess called the adjuvant
which is another kind of uh material
that isn't has nothing to do with
the um uh the actual fragment of virus
or whatever it is that you're trying to
become immune to it's simply something
and there are various different forms of
it it's it's simply something
that um uh
that um um
that is intended to get your immune
system
all wound up so that it
uh will uh mount a big response to the
thing that is actually being used to
make the vaccine so
this this what what tends to happen is
you get the vaccine injected it's
injected in you know
um into muscle or something and and um
uh it's um and then
this adjuvant gets your uh your innate
immune system
so wound up that it's going to basically
parade
immune cells past that site it's going
to say there's something really funky
going on here
get all that get those immune system
cells
to come check out what's happening and
so by doing that
it's it's um that that adjuvant is is
getting the immune system wound up
locally so it's gonna take a bunch of
immune system
cells and it's going to say come check
this out
come mount a response to the thing
that's here and typically when people
have sort of bad reactions to vaccines
the most common issue
is that adjuvant not the actual vaccine
thing itself then there are various
um uh very various issues with that
that's that's the thing to watch out for
more so than the actual vaccine itself
um
but um and they're usually different and
it's sort of a big art form
to get sort of adjuvants that that have
the right level of activity that that
produce the right amounts of
sort of uh make the immune system pay
attention to this and so on
okay so next question is uh when you try
and make a vaccine
what part of the
uh the the the potential attacker the
virus whatever it is
what part of that is the vaccine
so for instance if you have um a virus
it'll have you know let's say the 29 000
base pair
uh rna virus that is the thing that's
producing covert 19 and so on
um what uh you know that virus
has this particular form it has these
spike proteins sticking out of it that
make its whole
sort of crown like you know pictures and
so on
it has a bunch of different um different
pieces to it and
when when that virus is being made in a
cell that
all those different pieces will get
exposed on the on the cell
and what you have to do one thing you
have to do is pick which of those pieces
are you going to use to say this is the
one that we're going to teach our immune
systems
to go and attack and and so you have to
pick something which is
hopefully a piece of the virus that is
likely to be as the virus mutates and
viruses every
couple of weeks i think you know a virus
as it passes from person to person and
so on
will mutate by one base pair or so so
it's gradually
you know that and there are many many
many different versions of the of the um
coronavirus now of the covid19
um virus that exist and they all differ
by
by small amounts and one of the tricks
in designing
a vaccine is to make sure that you end
up with something which is generic
enough that it's very unlikely that
you'll still have
a working virus if that particular part
of the
of the sequence of the virus was changed
now of course things are
as usual more complicated than than in
biology than
than you can ever expect but there is a
notion of kind of cross reactivity
that is it could be the case that the
sequence is precisely blah blah blah
blah blah
but a sequence is just one off we'll
still be close enough
that there'll be a reasonable amount of
acti of reaction to that
so that even if you were off by one or
something you'll still
uh correctly be able to have the vaccine
produce the correct kind of immune
response blah blah
so okay so then is the question
boy this is complicated sorry um but i i
you know i suppose that
this is just the way that biology has
evolved to um
uh and i'm i'm skating over lots of
lots of details and there are also lots
of details that i probably don't know
um but uh uh but basic point is
that um what you've got to do to make a
vaccine is have
something in the vaccine that is sort of
enough relevant pieces
of the antigen that you're
that that um that you then mount an
immune response to
and then when the actual if the actual
virus
infects you then you'll say oh i know
that's a bad thing
i've already got a bunch of antibodies
to that which are
um but by that it's well that particular
section
i know i know it's bad because i see
this particular section
and i have things that can mount an
attack on any cell
that has this particular sequence
associated with it
okay so uh one of the issues so in the
case of
of of this particular uh uh
uh covert 19 virus um
the um uh one of the things that's been
done that's never been done before
is to make vaccines using messenger rna
and what the idea there is
normally you'll do things like take an
actual virus and kill it
and take fragments of the virus and that
will become the vaccine and you
have this whole setup but in the case of
of this
messenger rna set up what you're doing
is you're using
pieces of messenger rna that are um
uh messenger rna is is what
actually specifies to one of your cells
go make this protein it's the template
that basically specifies something you
should make and
and so the idea here is that you're
going to deliver
actual pieces of directly deliver pieces
of programs to our cells
to tell them to make things which are
the things
that that would be part of a vaccine to
this particular virus
and one of the the most tricky things
that took like a decade to figure out
was how to deliver that mrna
into the right part of the cell so that
it could be um
uh um
so so it could be um uh so it could
actually operate and and
be be used by the apparatus and the cell
and it's it's usually embedded in these
tiny little nano
what are they called um little nano
droplets
um that uh and that's that's the thing
that for example when these vaccines
have to be kept very cold and so on
it's to prevent those droplets from from
uh breaking down
and it's it's within those droplets
those droplets are able to be ingested
into a cell
get the mrna to the right place in the
cell have it start being used by the
cell
by the apparatus that the cell
uses to to make proteins and so on to
then
produce the things that will expose on
that cell
the things which are going to be the
things that would be needed to train the
immune system
to go through this whole other other set
of things that that one thinks about
by the way but to say one's injecting
messenger rna
one might say oh my gosh that means
you're injecting something like the
virus
but that's not true because all you're
injecting is little little fragments of
messenger rna which directly are
templates
for making proteins viruses have rna
that has
pieces in it that say how to replicate
more virus
which is a quite different thing so that
those those viruses that the
viral rna is has self-replication
built into it so that it can make more
viruses these pieces of mrna associated
with these vaccines
are just direct sort of instructions to
um
uh to generate um the appropriate
proteins
to to uh to to provide the things you
need for this vaccine
by the way i mean in the development of
you know one of the things that may
happen
uh this notion of using mrna to make
vaccines
is is a really it's not been done before
it's a it's a new thing it's kind of
something where
the science has really been accelerated
by the need to do it
right now the original thing that mrna
vaccines were developed for was
for dealing with cancer where one is
often wanting to um
you know the question why does the
immune system not get rid of cancers
when they show up
well because the immune system is
confused because the cancer seems like
it's one of your own cells
etc etc etc but if you could kind of
custom build some
some sort of uh you know you could
custom set up
a very particular immune response to the
very particular form of cells
that correspond to a cancer then you
could use your own immune system
to fight cancer it's an idea called
immunotherapy
of which there are a bunch of trials and
so on but it's not such a very old idea
for how to how to attack cancer but one
of the approaches to doing that
is well you make a very custom vaccine
based on the particular things that are
features of the cells
that are making your your cancer and so
that's what this rm
mrna technology was developed for um
and uh one of the consequences of of the
fact that it's been accelerated so much
in usage right now
may be a very a very interesting
direction
in uh in kind of being able to use
immunotherapy against cancer
um using sort of custom built um just as
these vaccines were sort of custom built
very quickly by the standards of vaccine
development
for this coronavirus so similarly you
you may be able to do that
for a particular tumor that a particular
person gets
and so on you may be able to build a
vaccine specifically for that
using same kind of technology now uh
let's see in in terms of describing how
the whole um
mechanism of uh of um um
the vaccines and so on works i mean so
so the big point is that you end up
with this sort of larger number of
antibodies against
the thing that you want to subsequently
attack
that's sort of what the vaccine achieves
also if you want to know were you sick
with a particular thing
you can directly go and measure and
there are different uh versions of this
the different forms of immunoglobulin
igg igm ige etc and they
they're different amounts of these that
are exist
at different stages in infection and for
long-term memory of an infection
but you can go and basically measure how
much
antibody of the particular kind that
would respond to a particular infection
do you have
and that's the way to potentially tell
whether you have had a given infection
now needless to say in the in the theory
that biology is always more complicated
than you can possibly imagine
um that's not the whole story because
in addition to immunity associated with
antibodies
the adaptive immune system has another
mechanism
quite different mechanism for producing
immunity so-called t-cell immunity
um and what's happening there is just as
there's this
this idea that you can have this marking
of things by antibodies etc etc etc
there's a whole different mechanism that
involves t cells
being able to bind to cells and decide
they're bad helper t
cells i guess they are binding to cells
deciding they're bad
and then causing those cells to be
attacked by by killer t cells and so on
um and so there's a thing called the t
cell receptor which is part of t
cells which also has this feature that
has many different variants
and it can also in a sense learn
from the existence of of antigens and so
on t cell immunity is much less well
understood
than b cell mediated kind of standard
sort of antibody
type immunity but it seems like for
coronaviruses in particular that t-cell
immunity
is probably pretty important it's also
much harder to to measure
because the these these immunoglobulins
that that are the the antibodies you
just they sort of just fall off and
they're
circulating little pieces of protein you
can just kind of measure how many of
those you have whereas for t
cells i think the only thing you can do
is actually get the genome sequence of
the t
cell on things and it's it's all rather
much more complicated um
so but but most likely some large
fraction of the immunity to coronavirus
is associated with t
cells so it's a little bit invisible in
the whole antibody system
and exactly what the relationship of of
vaccines
to stimulating that kind of immunity is
is less well understood
because it's harder to measure and it's
the whole thing is much less well
understood
than the case of of immunity associated
with um
uh with with the standard antibody
response and so on
so i mean this is a very beginning i
mean i i'm i'm
just just to give you some sense of how
complicated things are
in the immune system there are there are
antibodies
um and they're also potentially you can
end up with a feedback loop where you're
just producing more and more and more
antibodies
which would be very bad but then what
you end up with is sort of
anti-antibodies
which sort of reduce the number of
antibodies once you have too many it
will reduce them
and what you end up with is this whole
elaborate sort of dynamic equilibrium
between different kinds of components in
the immune system
and even people know that with t cells
actual t cells can go
and you know go and actually bind to
each other and actually
their actual physical interactions
between t cells that are important
in the way that the immune system works
it's a pretty complicated setup it's a
it's a sort of very dynamic network of
different different processes going on
still not very well understood and um
there are
a clearly well there are a lot of pieces
to this that are
important for understanding not only our
response to disease but also things like
autoimmunity when we get autoimmune
diseases
like uh oh i don't know asthma type one
diabetes multiple sclerosis
lots of different kinds of um
looks different kinds of autoimmune
diseases and autoimmune disease
what's happening is that it's it's
usually the t cells
are deciding that something that is
actually
something that is you is
is they say well actually no i don't
like that it's it there must be
something wrong with it
and they go and attack it and so like in
type 1 diabetes they attack the beta
cells of the pancreas
um and as if that was a foreign invader
and so they destroy those cells um and
that's um
uh that's the um or in in multiple
sclerosis it's the myelin sheaths of
nerves and so on
so it's kind of making a mistake and
it's saying this is something it should
be just looking for foreign stuff
but it says this thing that's actually
part of you seems to be something
foreign
and i need to go and attack it and one
of the things that's certainly been
observed in the last few decades is a
big
increase in the amount of autoimmune
diseases that are seen
in in some countries like the us and and
there's sort of
a bunch of questions about why that's
happening i think one of the more
prominent theories is
the theory that we live a much cleaner
life you know when we're kids
not growing up now uh you know in the
past
oh we might have had all kinds of uh you
know we might have had parasites living
in our guts because we've got
you know we eat food that is as is um
you know has little
worms or something terrible in it or
whatever and we might have you know
things are just much dirtier and we
would get much
more much more disease when we're young
and that um the immune system will be
trained in a different way
by getting all this disease and will be
more used to dealing with these outside
intruders
and the theory is that in sort of the
modern much cleaner world
the immune system kind of is like i got
to do something and so
it ends up going and attacking our own
cells rather than or
learning to attack our own cells rather
than concluding that it should attack
these um
uh these external um cells
and um
um the thing that um
okay so that was a very long description
of of something about vaccines
i think um uh what else to say about
them
probably lots of things to say about
them uh they're
it's a it's a kind of there's a lot of
cleverness involved in sort of all the
trade-offs
associated with um how to get um
uh how how a vaccine should be made to
operate how to make sure that
it doesn't start producing some kind of
weird autoimmunity
response etc etc etc and how to do that
across everybody because because
different people have different genomes
the the details of what self and what's
not self and so on will be different
between different people
um chances are that the the kinds of
things that are found in a virus are so
far away
from any piece of a genome in any human
that you don't really have to worry
about it but that's one of the issues
and and what can also happen is that you
say well i'm going to try for my vaccine
i'm going to try
these particular pieces of a virus for
example
and it might be that those aren't pieces
that
uh are very good for for
for the immune system to latch onto or
for recognizing when when the virus
attacks and so those are some of the
kinds of things that have to be tested
in figuring out whether a vaccine is
going to work
all right the
let's see that was a very long
description let's see were there
questions about this let me um
uh
okay there was some questions about um
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
let's see from pratt's
if a disease is such that the thing
which
kills is the immune response
could a vaccine based on these
principles be dangerous okay that's an
interesting question
so so one of the things that happens
with covet 19 for example
is that um some of the more dangerous
features of the disease are not the
virus itself
they are the uh response that your body
has
to the fact that there are cells
infected with a virus
particularly in one's lungs for instance
and there's
lungs are very sensitive they have what
is it i think 23 levels of branching of
little tiny tiny tiny
airways where you're where you have this
very very thin boundary between
your your bloodstream and the outside
and the air
allowing oxygen from the air to pass
into your bloodstream and so on
and uh and and go and um uh be
delivered to your various tissues by red
blood cells but
um there's that can be very sensitive
and if
if there's if there starts to be
inflammation if there start to be
kind of if your body is kind of mounting
a
a response it can kind of gum up those
little tiny airways
and that's really bad because it
prevents the the exchange of oxygen
and prevents you from being able to
successfully
deliver oxygen to you to your tissues
and so on
so that that whole cascade happens
because
there are lots of cells in your lungs
that are infected by the virus
and those cells are locally stimulating
some kind of inflammatory response
so when you have a vaccine the vaccine
the the actual things from the vaccine
they're just sitting in your arm or
whatever
um they're they're not those cells are
not
migrating around your body to start all
kinds of other things happening
so so that's not really a an issue for
that
locally you know you could get some sort
of local inflammation
you know at the site of where the
vaccine was given but you're not going
to get
the the the cells that were were uh
the things that were introduced when the
vaccine was given in the case of mrna
vaccines
it'll actually be cells that are that
are produced those cells
aren't expected to kind of migrate
around and start showing up and
and um having an effect elsewhere in any
case those
those um uh yeah so i think that that's
that's
not something one should consider a
likely risk um it's only just the local
thing of
of you know when for some vaccines
uh you would actually get something
which is very much like like with the
smallpox
um uh let's see some of these vaccines i
think smallpox did that is that right
some of these vaccines you might
actually get particularly from live
virus
you might actually get you know one puck
from the smallpox so to speak
right at that location it doesn't
migrate elsewhere in your body
but it does it exists right there
but but doesn't start affecting other
things
okay so somebody is commenting here this
is not how it works
infection gets in kills some cells
immune system picks up on the waste
products this triggers antibodies
localized to the
no that's the innate immune system not
um
i think um that that's not the um
uh uh the the the mechanism that i've
been talking about is mostly antibodies
which is the adaptive immune system um
but you know i have to say doing this
whole um description of
all of these aspects of biology from
memory is is a
is um uh is challenging um
because um but uh i think i think i have
it right
um let's see
um well let me just
address maybe one or two other questions
here
um there's a question from
david uh it's more a history question
have i met tim berners-lee doug
engelbach ed feigenbaum shafi gobasa
yes i think i do i do a hundred percent
on that
i've actually not i i never met douglas
we had a long phone conversation once
um so i'm i'm i'm hitting four for four
in terms of networking there
um
let's see
uh
oh boy
um
it's a lot of very interesting questions
here my gosh
the
um all right i'll address a couple here
um udacio is saying
his three-year-old sister tells him that
she doesn't like math
and doesn't want to talk about it how to
change
somebody's mind about math
you know it's a little bit of a question
what math is
and um uh and what you know
unfortunately
math that gets taught in school is not
necessarily the most
interesting aspects of math um
you know i think the essence of what
math is
is about kind of taking these concepts
like numbers
and geometry and so on and seeing what
can be figured out from those things
so i would say the the uh the the the
the challenge in in having people be
interested in math
is there's math over here which is some
kind of abstract thing
and that's what somebody is interested
in over here and the question is is
there a bridge between this abstract
thing
and something someone is interested in
so for instance
if people are interested in kind of
visual kinds of things
well there's things you can do with math
to make visual kinds of things whether
it's
oh i don't know things with polyhedra or
whether it's things with cellular
automaton patterns things like that
there are kind of ways to take things
that are kind of mathy things
and um and make them visible or things
where one might be curious you know you
take a polyhedron you take some
and you say you know how many corners
does it have how many edges does it have
how many faces
let's do a piece of arithmetic and and
compare those
and discover euler's formula that
connects those things
by looking at different polyhedra i mean
that there are there are sort of
different kinds of mathy things that um
um i think uh are potentially
interesting to people another one that
i've
i've tried on kids a bunch of times and
sometimes it works sometimes it doesn't
is um just uh you know for kids
know some arithmetic um is is like
do the thing just take pair of numbers
one plus one
equals two uh two plus one equals three
keep doing this but you never once once
you get
to uh you'll get up to five plus eight
um and you might say that's equal to
thirteen but just ignore the one at the
beginning of that
just say five plus eight and just keep
only the ones co
only the the units column five plates
plus eight equals three let's say
you're just keeping the um you're doing
it mod ten you're ignoring the um
uh the multiples of ten and so on keep
doing that start with one plus one
keep doing that same thing what you're
making is
you know in the mathy level is the
fibonacci sequence mod 10
it's kind of an interesting exercise see
what happens with that sequence
you'll discover something interesting if
you do it and um that's a good uh
that's that's something i don't know
some uh in my observation some fraction
of young kids
get really interested in what's going to
happen and um
and then eventually discover it and get
get rather excited um
but you know there are different kinds
of things that are i think the challenge
is
what is somebody interested in how does
that relate to kinds of
abstract concepts that um that we
usually associate with math um now
there's a question here what are time
crystals um that's a
friend of mine actually who um who i
think developed those ideas
but um here's let me let me try a little
bit of an explanation of this what is a
crystal
crystal is a you know when you have a
solid
it has atoms in it and the question is
how are those atoms arranged
and the answer is in a crystal the atoms
are arranged in a very regular way
so there'll be a whole grid and the
crystal depending on their different
kinds of crystals
there's 17 standard kinds i guess
and that they're all different kinds of
grids like a salt crystal
sodium chloride is a cubic crystal and
the atoms in that cubic crystal are
arranged
on a cubic lattice so so there's kind of
a whole
three-dimensional grid of where the
where the atoms are arranged and it's
all in little cubic pieces that are
that are all uh stuck together and um so
it's just
an arrangement where there's there's a
whole grid of cubes
so diamond for example has a different
way that the atoms are arranged but it's
always very regular
there's a kind of a a whole regular grid
of things there
and so if you look at one piece of a
crystal and
um it'll always look the same the
configuration of atoms in one piece of
the crystal
will always be exactly the same as the
configuration of atoms in another piece
of the crystal that's kind of the
definition of a crystal
that has that kind of periodic
regularity that it's made of these
sort of identical units that just get
repeated over and over again
so that's an ordinary crystal so another
kind of thing is a liquid crystal
so a liquid crystal is is something
where there are molecules that are big
long
stringy molecules um like cholesterol is
is uh it happens to be one that's
commonly used i guess as a
common type of thing that that can act
this way
and the point is that the um that these
molecules
they usually uh in a liquid crystal
what happens is the position of these
molecules is kind of random
but the molecules are all lined up in
the same direction
so so that even though the positions
even though where these molecules are is
random
the orientation of the molecules which
are long stringy molecules
the orientation is some actually they're
not so long molecules but but the
their molecules with a definite
direction to them they're all all lined
up
in a liquid crystal and that's why for
example light gets polarized
when it can go when it goes through a
liquid crystal because it can only
the only the vibrations of light that
are
sort of along the direction of of these
of these sort of fingers
can get through and the ones opposite to
that the ones that 90 degrees to that
can't
so okay that's a liquid crystal okay so
the idea of a time crystal
is something where the the atoms aren't
arranged in the things things aren't
arranged in
a um in a definite uh sort of
periodic arrangement in space they're
not arranged in a definite orientation
but instead in time things keep on
coming back to being the same again
it's something where there's sort of a
repeating thing happening in time
that's the idea i think there are some
places where this has potentially been
observed
um but that's um that's kind of the
notion is is when
when it's it's it's a pure thing where
what you're having is
something where the mechanics of the
system it may rattle around all over the
place
but every so often it's coming back to
exactly the same form
and i mean there are there are simple
cases where that happens with waves and
things like this
but there are more elaborate cases
potentially with materials where you can
have things like that happen
that that's the idea at least
there's a question from radmir here we
have an explanation of why people have a
sense of discreetness
talking about symbols and objects and so
on is the world
implicitly discreet or do we just
perceive it that way
oh that's an interesting question so
in our current theory of physics that
that i've had the pleasure of developing
over the last year or so
it looks like we're discovering that
ultimately the universe really is made
of discrete things
but those discrete things those kind of
atoms of space are really really tiny
perhaps 10 to the minus 100 meters
across or
that that's their effective size so
that's really really tiny compared to
anything that we experience
so at the level at which we're dealing
with things
the fact that the universe may
ultimately be made of discrete things is
sort of irrelevant
now the question is when we choose to
think about things
how come we we we see the world made of
these you know
trillions and trillions of objects and
we in order for us to reason about
what's happening in the world
we don't want to talk individually about
all these trillions and trillions of
objects
we instead want to um uh be able to talk
about
um uh we
we don't our brains don't let us kind of
independently reason
about all the different objects all the
different atoms that are floating around
our brains like to find it find it only
possible
to have sort of a a single thread of
things that we're thinking about
and there we have to kind of bucket
together lots of different
detailed oh there's this is what's
happening in all these different million
atoms that are going on
we have to say uh you know that's a
um you know
that's a chair or something all those
atoms that make up the chair
we just describe it as that's a chair
rather than individually talking about
all those individual atoms
because our brains are not well suited
to tracking all those
all those millions of different thing
atoms in the chair
our brains kind of want to have this one
kind of symbolic object that they're
talking about
now why is this does it need to be that
way
uh my guess is that in a recent
some recent thinking i've done about
this my guess is that it's a very
fundamental feature
of the thing that we think of as
consciousness that it has this kind of
notion of a single thread
that we don't get to talk about sort of
all these different things going on
we're insisting on sort of talking about
a single thread of things going on
i mean another way to put it is we could
try to describe the world in terms of
all those separate atoms doing their
separate thing
but that would take a huge amount of
computation to know what was going to
happen in the world
much better that we'd be able to say
pick up the chair
it will move in this way rather than
study each individual atom in the chair
and see what it will do
we want to be able to if we have only a
limited amount of computational ability
we have to be able to sort of group
things together and say let's talk about
the whole chair
rather than talking about the individual
atoms in the chair so i think that it's
a feature
of the fact that we have limited
computational ability
that we choose to describe the world
in terms of these aggregate things
because if we didn't do that
we could not make any predictions about
how the world works
because we'd have to talk about all
these different tiny little incoherent
pieces
that make up the um uh the the elements
of the world
uh rather than being able to use a
limited amount of computation to say
some general things
about what's going to happen in the
world now why is it possible to do that
could it be the case that we live in a
world
where there are no aggregate things to
talk about where
where the aggregates you know dissolve
immediately and where there's no
coherence to what's happening in the
world
that's an interesting question i think
that in our in our theory of physics
what we've learned is that there are
particular forms of coherence in the
world
that are actually summarized pretty well
by the the two great pillars of 20th
century physics
relativity and quantum mechanics um and
that those
those are kind of what tell us that
there is a way to talk about
features of the world coherently so to
speak it might not be the case
it might be the case that every atom you
have to talk about separately
but in fact we know that that isn't true
that we can still have
useful things to say by talking about
these atoms in the aggregate
now our uh it's sort of a little bit of
a self-fulfilling prophecy because
in a sense the things we choose to
interact with
are the things about which we can talk
uh in the aggregate so to speak
you know there are things that might
exist in the physical world
that will be very difficult for us to
reason about but we don't choose to use
those for our technology
or sort of they don't show up in our
everyday life our biological evolution
has not led us to have sensors for those
things
and so on in other words the things that
are part of our experience
and part of the world that we build for
ourselves are things
that we are capable of kind of uh
handling
in this way where we can use only
limited computational resources
to be able to handle those things and as
i say my guess is that there's sort of a
a whole kind of connection with the
thing that we have the perception of
being consciousness
that is this sort of notion of being
able of dealing with things with a sort
of single thread
of of um uh of kind of coherent
um experience rather than something
where we're breaking into all these
different threads of experience that
that's
that's an essential feature of the way
that we sort of think about thinking
about things so to speak
so that was a so i think my answer is
that
the fact that the world can be broken
into these kind of coherent lumps that
we can talk about
symbolically objects and things like
this that is an interesting feature
of sort of the fundamental basic science
of how the world is put together it is i
believe an inevitable feature of this
thing i call the principle of
computational equivalence
which i think is a really core principle
that is just a
an abstract principle that turns out to
be true it's not obvious that it will be
true
but it turns out to be true and it turns
out abstractly
it seems to be true and um that that
principle that one principle has sort of
a bunch of trickle-down effects
one of which is the thing called causal
invariance which
then has the effect that it becomes
possible
to identify these aggregate features of
the world
um that uh that exist
then those are reflected in some of the
principles we've learned in physics for
example
and those are the things that we are
keying into
to kind of be able to reason about the
world
now you know an interesting question is
the kind of the potential you know
extraterrestrial intelligences the other
intelligences so to speak
do they key into the same aspects of the
world do they identify
the same kinds of objects if they have
bounded computational resources
as well and inevitably they will have if
if they um
in order to act as something which could
plausibly be considered
a consciousness-like thing i think they
sort of have to have bounded
computational resources
then it um the question is do they key
into the same
kind of uh you know making things into
objects and symbolic and so on as we do
and the answer is there's no reason to
think they would and um
there are probably sort of utterly
different views of the universe
that might still at some level are still
at some level the description
of the same kind of computational uh
infrastructure of the universe but it's
described in an utterly different way
it's not described in terms of space and
time and objects and so on
it's described in some way that is
completely alien to us
and which i have a hard time even
imagining but it's an interesting thing
to try to think about what is the kind
of
utterly different description of the
world that you could have
that could still ultimately be at a
formal level describing the same world
but it's utterly different and the
things we consider to be
objects oh yeah it's a chair could be to
somebody else
oh that's you know some very incoherent
thing and only the combination of the
chair and the air around it and this and
that the other that's the thing that we
identify as an object
all right i should um i should probably
uh
i'll be wrapping up soon i'm rather late
for something else i was supposed to be
doing but you guys are asking such
interesting questions
um okay there's a history question here
from don
i'm i'm going to do another uh history q
a i think next wednesday so let's
let's put that in that um
oh boy okay there are
so many questions here well um
um
yeah i think i have to i think i have to
take these another time there's an
interesting question from mark here
about uploading data
about human body and fixing everything
if we have the computing power and sort
of ai
to understand things can we do that
you know it's a tricky thing because we
are the only known example of molecular
scale computing
the computers we have operate in a very
different way from the way we operate we
operate using these chemical processes
that happen at a molecular scale we
don't even have a good kind of
we can we can emulate those processes
but they're definitely not happening
in the same kind of molecular way that
they happen in us i've actually recently
been thinking about ways to think about
the kind of molecular processes uh the
computations that happen in sort of
molecular processes in us
but um uh there's also the question of
you know we're a pretty complicated
computation that's going on
that all our cells in our bodies are
doing all these complicated things
and you say well something's going wrong
whatever wrong means
um it's um uh you know can we fix it
that's a tricky thing it's a very
difficult thing we don't even know how
to do that
for a computer operating system we don't
even know if your computer operating
system is running and it's going to
crash
sometime um your computer's going to die
in effect um you know how do we avoid
that happening what bits do we have to
change
in the running operating system to
prevent it from crashing that's a
difficult problem which we don't know
very much about
and that's what we kind of have to
emulate if we're going to think about
how to do that for humans and also in
the case of humans
we've got to deliver that um in
sort of at the right molecular scale in
the right place to be able to make that
intervention so to speak
and i think in terms of of the um
uh sort of can you just take uh you know
let's say the content of a brain
and just emulate it and sort of upload
it and have a an uploaded consciousness
so to speak that
that is just like us um i mean that's a
that's a tricky almost philosophical
question
um at what point uh you know how to what
extent
you know to what extent is that is that
you know if you have a copy of yourself
that is a perfect copy of all the
operation of your neurons
is it you so to speak do you have the
perception that it's you
is it is it you um and i think that's uh
maybe we can discuss this another time
there's a whole
uh sort of collection of philosophical
issues about this there's usually this
uh
ship of theseus problem where somebody
says i've got a ship it's
theseus's ship and um it's uh
and now oh a piece of it breaks so i'm
gonna replace that part i'm gonna
replace all the planks
on this and eventually i'm going to
replace the mast of the ship
i'm going to replace the rudder of the
ship i'm going to replace this part of
the ship
i'm going to replace that part of the
ship and pretty soon
there's no piece of timber on the ship
this is from ancient times
um there's no piece of timber on the
ship that's the same as it was when
theseus had the ship
is it still the ship of theseus or not
you know what makes it the same thing
even though all its parts have been
replaced
and that's kind of part of the issue of
kind of as you
for example let's say you incrementally
sort of start
sharing your memories with some external
digital device
or you even do a single uploading event
what is it you know to what extent is it
you and to what extent is it not you
interesting philosophical question
maybe for another time all right um
thank you very much for a lot of um
really uh
um oh i've there's one last question i
can't resist this one
has anyone looked at the complexity of
cell can we not say that exhibits
intelligence
can intelligence exist without brains
you know
in in my kind of view of of sort of how
things work a lot of the story is about
computation
if you have some formal piece of input
and you have a system that is going and
figuring out things from that input
according to rules that's sort of that's
doing a computation
and that's the core of what intelligence
is doing it is doing computations like
that
and there is nothing to say that the
the kind of um the the thing that we
call intelligence
has to exist in in our particular
example of it exists in human brains and
all that kind of thing
but this as soon as you have a system
that it does
any kind of sophisticated computation
it's intelligence of some sort
it isn't human intelligence necessarily
unless we sort of very specifically set
it up that way it's intelligence
but it's kind of alien intelligence that
we can't necessarily relate to
but it is nevertheless intelligent so
when you ask you know can a cell be
intelligent
in that sense the answer i suspect is is
yes in this sense the question is can we
tell
can we relate its kind of computation
its thinking so to speak to what we
humans do i mean if we take the immune
system for instance
you know that all these complicated
interactions between cells and all that
kind of thing
can we um can we um uh can we
relate that to um uh
you know are those things doing
something that is like the kind of
computations that exist in something
like human intelligence
yes the computations are no doubt as
powerful
the issue is can we kind of relate those
computations to things that we imagine
our human intelligence and the things
that we sort of think of as human
purposes and so on
anyway very interesting stuff thank you
very much for all of these uh
questions and comments and um
uh see you again